under communism you understand everybody
is equal but some people are more equal
than others and we're seeing that play
out right now in the
socialist supporting squad there's uh
some members of the squad these radicals
in the democratic party
who want some certain privileges
particularly when it comes
to the vaccine there should be no
special privileges for anybody
everybody has got to get exactly the
same sort of stuff
that is what we are told by
these socialist supporting radicals in
the democratic party and yet
those same most vocal socialists
are the ones who want special privileges
for themselves namely
ayanna presley who is known as the ringo
of the squad
she's sort of the least important member
of the squad she's you know at least aoc
puts on a good show
or even ilhan omar is sort of
cartoonishly wicked and evil
giggling about al qaeda ayanna presley
just hasn't been able
to shine quite as well as the other ones
ayanna presley
is coming out now to get the coronavirus
vaccine even though she's
young seems relatively healthy she's
coming out and getting it
before a lot of older people do even
before a lot of
healthcare workers do and she's
advocating a totally new arrangement a
list of priorities for who gets the
vaccine
including not just people like herself
but also
criminals yes i did have the vaccine
administered yesterday
uh in in order to maintain the
continuity of government
but also because you know i live with
like millions of americans
i'm two pre-existing conditions um and
and doing my part uh both to keep myself
safe so that i can continue to do my job
to fight for my district and the
american people
keeping my family safe but also stopping
the spread
of this virus which has raged out of
control which has everything to do with
the willful criminality
of donald trump and i'm going to
continue to fight for our most
vulnerable
communities who have been
disproportionately impacted by the virus
for our health care workers for our
essential workers
for incarcerated men and women to be
prioritized in the distribution of the
vaccine
wait a second what hold on i totally
expect
these political hacks like ayanna
presley to come and say look it's very
important
for the continuity of government that i
some random congressman more or less
unimportant to the function of
government that i
receive this vaccine before anyone else
does i have to i wish i didn't have to
but i have to
i'm so integral to the functioning of
the government
you could get rid of half the members of
congress wouldn't change a thing about
the way the government works
but i have to get okay you expect that
but then at the end she says yeah we
need to give it to people you know
who've been marginalized who need the
vaccine more than others and
to uh incarcerated men and women and
that's what you need hold on
incarcerated men and women i guess
that's the euphemism for criminals
criminals get the vaccine before my
grandma does are you out of your mind
have you lost your i don't know that she
had the mind to lose in the first place
but certainly if she ever had one it is
gone
no criminals don't get prioritized
for the vaccine we've taken
our understanding of criminal justice
and completely flipped it on its head
you see this most notably on the left
here
where they cry and they wail and they
gnash their teeth and they run their
garments
whenever some triple murderer rapist
serial killer gets his just desserts
in the execution chamber but they clamor
they
they rally they cheer in support of
slaughtering a million innocent babies a
year
that's ex that's not just a little moral
confusion that's a
an exact inversion of of a serious moral
framework
and that's what we're seeing here i'm
not saying you need to torture the
criminals
i'm not saying you need to be cruel to
the criminals
i'm not saying you need to deprive the
criminals of the vaccine
but they don't get first dibs are you
crazy
yes this woman is crazy and
i should point out selfish and cynical
because she's taking this vaccine
before other people would get it
[Music]
you